- Good morning, Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe and I
believe that you have something
special that when you unleash it,
it will be able to change the world.
So, to help you on your
journey, today's message is,
"Master one thing."
Over to you, Tony Robbins.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- Most people who start a
business very often will start
two and three, four, or more,
and the reason that they do
it is because the first one
isn't succeeding or they no longer...
- They lack patience.
- Exactly right.
And so, what happens to that person,
is they're never going to
be successful in most cases,
unless they get lucky.
You get lucky and bounce across
something that's easier to do.
But most are always lookin'
for that next level.
What my view is, is it's
great to test all these things
but you got to find what is your flagship?
What is it that you're going
to commit your soul to?
Because if you don't do that,
the inevitable challenges
are going to come up and you're
going to then move on to something
else more enjoyable.
- 100 percent.
- And so, the other thing I look at is,
business is about constantly,
not only adding such massive
value, doing more for
others than anybody else,
but it's also, simultaneously,
about your own psychology,
it's your ability to go
through thresholds of control.
It's like, I can remember
when I didn't have $50,000
to keep the doors open on my company
and I have 12 employees,
and 11 wanted to quit 'cause
they hated the person running the show.
And $50,000 to me, is like,
$500 million to me today
and I figured out how to
get through that threshold.
And once I did, like,
all the problems related
to that were handled.
I know you've done this as well.
And then I, you know, I
had a $5 million lawsuit,
it was totally unfair and unjust,
and I finally had to just,
the amount of time, and energy, and money,
I had to just bite the bullet and do it.
And $5 million was more than I'd ever met.
Then I had a partner, who
took a company that was losing
a million dollars a day and
turned it to $1.5 billion
in positive Ebitda, I'm not
mentioning names, Amway.
And, he wanted me to join him in business
with some other partners, not
doing the multi-level side,
did the business, put in 10 million bucks,
we all put in $10 million,
there's $40 million in that.
But I signed joint and several,
which I didn't understand
in those days what that meant.
And two of my partners were
supposedly billionaires,
and they went broke.
We bought some more companies,
I ended up with $120 million
in debt that I was on the hook for,
no one else had any money.
And I'm getting up to do a
seminar wanting to throw up.
That was a new threshold of control.
So, when you know, when
you ski or you snowboard,
and you think, you're just new at it,
and you think you're
going down a blue or green
and it turns out to be a double black?
(laughs)
And then you're like, "What the fuck?"
And so, you have two choices,
one is you start to go down
and you freak out and you're going to die,
you slam down on the ground
and you try to hang on
for dear life.
Or, the other is, baby, you
focus on where you want to go
and find a way to curve.
- And go.
- You find a way to cut.
And once you do it a couple of times...
- You get used to it.
- You have no more fear of that element.
Now my biggest one, out of
that, that led me to a billion.
I have 31 companies now
to give you an idea.
Seven different industries
as diverse as, like,
you know, stem cells to virtual reality.
We have the exclusive to the
NBA now in virtual reality
to give you an example.
I got 1200 employees,
we're on three continents,
and we've got $5 billion in sales.
But I did that because I first
stayed on one frickin' thing.
- That's exactly right.
- And I got so masterful at it.
- So one of the messages
that I've repeated over
and over and over again in this channel
because it's so important,
is the number one rule
about making money.
Which is, if you want to make money,
you have to provide value.
It's the number one
rule about making money.
The more value you can provide somebody,
a client who's facing a
problem of frustration,
the more money you're
going to be able to make,
going to be able to charge.
If you want to make money
quickly, provide value quickly.
That's how it works.
The challenge is being
able to provide the value.
'Cause when you first
start off in business,
you don't know enough to
provide amazing value.
You can provide some value,
you can help people out,
but you can't provide enough value
to charge a premium price, yet.
And that comes through mastery.
That comes from understanding
the thing that you want
to be amazing at, that you
want to be world-class at,
that you want to be the
Tony Robbins of, at.
What is that thing?
And go all in it and focus
on it and get better,
and get better, and get
better, and get better.
You can get better quickly if
you focus and practice on it.
You can outpace your
competition really quickly,
like I did at my agency,
because I was making
multiple videos a day,
where they were making one video a month,
or one video a week,
and having a really hard time with that.
You can get better really
quickly with dedicated,
focused, effort on it.
But most people don't do that.
Too many entrepreneurs
are super scattered.
And it's extra hard because,
maybe, you have a full-time job
you haven't quit yet, you've got family
and other commitments.
Plus, you have 100 ideas in your head,
and so, you're starting
this, and doing this,
and starting that, and doing this.
And then, if I look at your
productivity of actually moving
forward on that thing that
you have the ability to be
Tony Robbins level at, how much
time are you really spending
on that one thing?
Will it be like a start,
and a stop, and a start,
and a stop.
And, maybe, on Monday and then, pull back,
and then, maybe again on
Friday, and then pull back,
you never put in enough
actual work on that thing
to become the Tony Robbins.
To become world-class at that thing.
And that's where you're going
to provide lots of value
and that's where you're
going to make lots of money.
That's what you need
to get really good at,
otherwise you're going to constantly
play in this average zone.
If you look at this channel,
you look at the Top 10 series
that you guys love, and is
what, you know, we're known for,
there's lots of people that
are trying to copy that.
There's lots of people who
are tryin' to make their
own Top 10's, it's great.
We do one, five days a week.
Like, we're workin' on new
Top 10 five days a week,
we've been doing it for,
I don't know how long,
I don't know how many Top
10's we have, there's a lot.
If you want to come
into this market, right,
if you want to now
compete, a lot of people,
all they do is, they
make, like, one a month,
two a month.
And they're tryin' to
make it and they're tryin'
to do better, but it's,
like, this start and stop,
and start and stop.
You're never going to win by
making that level of quantity
'cause the quantity leads to the quality.
The more you do, the
better it's going to get,
and the more you'll find
your own flavor and style.
You'll find a way to make
your own top 10 that's
different than mine, on
it's own path, right?
Like, you can't just be a
carbon copy of somebody else.
You can start by copying,
but then you need to find
your own twist and maneuvers,
and make it better.
But it's not going to happen
doin' it once or twice a month,
when people in your industry
are doing it everyday.
Right?
You need to get better.
You need to get mastery.
And so, one of the hardest
things for a lot of entrepreneurs
to do is to focus,
because it's so exciting
and it's so fun to work on
lots of different ideas, right?
If you're an ideas person, it's just,
"Oh, this is great and this
is great, oh, McDonald's could
"really use this and
Staples could use this."
And, I can walk into any
business and think of ways
that they could make things better.
And that's exciting, and
that's a great brain exercise,
but you don't actually
get great at anything 'til
you start executing, you start doing.
And so, being able to take those ideas
and then focus to say, "Of
all these things, this is what
"I want to get really great at.
"This is the skill that
want to learn to be one
"of the best in the world
that's providing insane value
"to my customers, to my market.
"Outpace my competition, make
a ton of money in the process,
"have a huge impact on the world.
"This is what I want to do."
It's the people who are
masters at their skill set
who end up making the big
impact, making the big dollars,
making the big changes.
And the people who are
average or just above average,
constantly live a small life.
And so, you have to make a
choice, what do you want to do?
Do you want to start and
stop, and start and stop,
and never get good at anything
and bounce from one idea
to the other?
And, even if you have one
great idea, to never really,
fully commit to it and
then, 10 years blow by,
and nothing major has happened.
'Cause you've never actually
committed serious time
to doing it.
Or do you want to say,
"No, this is important.
"My time is important,
this project's important,
"the impact that this is
going to have is important.
"The result that it's
going to create for myself,
"for my family, for my community,
for the people around me,
"is important.
"And I'm going to dedicate my
self to becoming a master at it."
Stop tryin' to be okay
at a thousand things
and master the one thing that you could be
Tony Robbins level at.
Do that and start having
tremendous success.
So, the question of the day, today, is
"What do you want to master?"
What is the big thing
that you want to master,
it's your big goal, you
want to be one of the best
in the world at this thing.
What is it?
I'm curious, leave it
on the comments below.
I want to see your answers.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Tim Hoven,
from Hoven Farms.
Tim thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- I came to the mindset
when I was in film school,
Mark, that I did not want
to be a one-and-done,
I did not want to be a flash-in-the-pan.
I wanted to be here for the long haul.
When Kurasowa, the great Akira Kurasowa,
was doing press for one
of his last films, Ran,
his journalists asked him,
"You're one of the greatest
"master filmmakers of all time,
"what else do you still have to learn?"
And Kurosawa said, "I still
have the universe to learn."
So, I was in film school
and that blew my mind.
The baddest motherfucka
ever, he's 85, 83, 84,
and he says he still has
the universe to learn
as far as storytelling?
That really hit me, like,
you know, you really got to,
like the jazz term, you got
to stay in the woodshed.
You know, you got to shed,
you know, and constantly
be on it, perfectin' your craft
and never get to the point
that you trick yourself into
thinkin' that you know it all.
It's a life-long journey, you know,
to tell stories, how you craft them.
Just be a good storyteller,
and you do that by,
having a body of work, so it's always been
on the body of work.
- In everything I do, everyday,
everyday we're going down
and working on the play, the whole thing.
Everything is to get to a point where
you don't have to act it.
That all you're doing
is going through thing
and you're not acting it.
You just know what you're
talkin' about so much that
you don't have to act it.
You know what you're saying,
you know why you're saying it,
and what you're talkin' about,
you know who you're talkin' about,
and how you feel when you talk about it,
then you don't have to act it.
And that's what the whole thing is about.
- And by the time I got to
college, I made this album
called The Language of My World.
(cheering)
And with this album, I did the same thing,
I locked myself in my room
for, like, all of college.
That was it, I just worked
my ass off, in my room.
And kept writing, kept
recording, and I wasn't great
going into college, but
by the time I got out,
I had, kind of, like, learned
a little through the cracks.
And by the time, when
I got out of college,
I read this book called
Outliers by Malcolm Gladwell.
Nobody's read it here.
(cheering)
One person.
Anyway, this book examines...
This book examines this theory, right?
And Malcolm Gladwell
makes this point, he says,
"It's not about what your
born with, it's not about
"the talent that your born
with, it's about the hours
"that you put into that talent."
And he says, "If you want to
be a master of whatever it is
"that you love to do, if you
want to develop that craft
"to it's utmost potential,
what you got to do is work.
"You have to work a lot,
you have to put in hours."
And he says, "That if you
put in around 10,000 hours
"into that one thing, that
eventually, you will master
"that craft."
And I don't know how close
I am to 10,000 hours,
but every single time we step on a stage,
we get one step closer.